mrs. Kimsey ready yes and playback 3 2 1
hey et it's Kensi and I'm taking you
guys on behind the scenes of my new
music video motives so come on in the
lyrics of this song are really powerful
girl who did you wrong like where is
this coming from it's actually a friend
it's not about like a boy or a
relationship or anything I just noticed
that they weren't actually being my
friend for just me
I was just for like followers and clout
and them getting so like when you're
angry and life put it in writing makes
gonna make some art out of it so tell me
about the concept of this video we're
here in like a very gritty dark gym um
did you come up with this concept and
and why here in a boxing gym because
it's very like girl empowering it's like
a gym run by girls the song was produced
by girls directed by a girl Lily watch
kick and then all of the dancers are
girls so I wanted to make sure this was
like all based around girls because
girls are super cool and they should be
recognized
knowing you there's always gonna do some
fierce choreography oh yeah we
definitely went above and beyond on this
one very hardcore rumor Noel
choreographed this and I always love
when she choreographs my stuff it's very
like heavy and cool and yeah I feel like
everybody's doing at home cuz there's
still some of those mints that you can
do at home which is really you know we
love rewinding and trying to replicate
the moves
[Music]
lots of artists don't dance and that's
okay but I feel like it's something that
you really prioritize why is that
important to you well most of my music
is you know like groovy and you can
dance to it and I feel like it makes my
videos more like empowering and like fun
and like people want to watch it because
they just like see dancers and love
dancers and I'm like obsessed with
watching dance videos so like I
definitely want to make one I get a
little nostalgic whenever I see you
because we really grew up watching you
on TV would you say that your training
on Dance Moms
helped you get to this point like where
you're just nailing choreography
constantly are you thinking about things
you learned when you're here in the ring
you know giving it your all to the
camera oh for sure I can learn dances in
like two minutes if I have to and that
definitely helped me and give me gave me
an advantage and also I just learned
everything but I know from that from
doing that so I'm very thankful for it
and yeah I wouldn't be dancing if that
didn't happen so I almost quit to like
play soccer so we wouldn't have these
saucy bobs
[Music]
or are you involved in picking out what
it is you're gonna wear yes I do pick
out pretty much everything that I wear I
have the stylist and she brings all of
the clothes in and then I pick my
favorites and then I just choose which
ones I want to wear so what was it about
this cuz you've got like harnesses then
comes combat boots can you get a shot of
like the whole outfit what's what was
the vibe you were going for I feel like
it was just like boss lady I couldn't
help but notice we've got a really nice
oily sheen going on which looks so sick
on camera may I add what's the secret
oh really legit cooking olive oil yeah
literally like you could throw me in an
oven right now is this the grown-up new
Kenzi is this the most mature like the
coolest we've seen you yet definitely
most mature probably not adult yet like
teenage my tease but yeah I definitely
want to be more mature than I my music
was before and I'm loving it and all my
fans are growing up with me so I feel
like though completely get it we have a
little surprise for you if we can get
the et iPad a little someone wanted to
wish you well today on your big shoot
monkey it's bubs I just wanted to say I
love you good morning our friends here
told me to man to send you a little
surprise video and I love the idea and I
just wanted to tell you how proud I am
of you and how much I love you and how
amazing it is to be on this journey with
you and watching you this amazing
talented beautiful superstar that you
are and I can't wait to see you in a
little bit but I hope this video can
wait go I don't like it I know you're
exhausted and yeah I just love you so
much and I'm so so so so so proud of you
we'll be so much bye oh we melts a
little bit every time you guys post
something adorable and couples
Goldsworthy on your Instagram what is it
about that guy that just kind of like
makes your heart flutter he's literally
the sweetest person he's so supportive
with everything he's coming here and
supporting and he like I told it was
like you do not need to come and he was
like no I'm gonna be there for like five
hours like I would never do that I'm
sorry but he doesn't listen to a lot of
like this style of music but like he
just loves everything that I do it's
been what like four months yeah are we
changing the l-word yeah
[Music]
when people watch the music video for
motives how do you hope they feel I just
want them to start dancing like that's
literally it
I don't really care if people like the
song I just want something to get out of
it
I promise you're gonna like this on
where do you see yourself in five years
hopefully this but just like way more
advanced and like selling out stadiums
going on tours just like Kennedy I'm
just so proud of you and of course your
[ __ ] now that is - I just love that
you've grown into such a strong woman
and this song is going to be such a big
inspiration to all those girls out there
I love it so much
[Music]
that's Ravi T thank you guys so much for
coming behind the scenes with me and I
hope you guys enjoyed it
love you
[Music]